we're kicking it off with a mac and
cheese makeover in today's food news
okay i don't know if anyone here knows
how i feel about mac and cheese uh yeah
we do
um well i'm obviously very excited
because i've been chomping at the mac
and cheese bit for this pop sugar
reports that craft has turned their
classic noodles pink
for valentine's and they say it's the
same
classic craft with a taste of just a
hint of candy flavor
shall we yeah uh-huh i just want to say
out loud it doesn't look super
appetizing
right like like against nature
let's try it
hmm
well um i'm in you're in yeah
it's um it they actually i have to say
kind of mastered the ratio because when
i heard the mac and cheese was going
sweet
i'm not gonna lie i was like well check
this out you get your mac n cheese
and then you get this packet and so it
makes the color
and the flavor just slightly altered
i'm in really yeah well then you can
have mine
[Laughter]
all right well and if you're headed into
the weekend with a feeling just a little
broken-hearted this valentine's season
ready to
move on from an ex-boyfriend or an
ex-girlfriend well there's
news for you delish reports that hooters
wants to help yeah hooters so
here's the plan if you can shred a photo
of your ex
they'll high-five you with some free
wings you can go to their website
upload a photo of your ex and then you
can choose how you want to destroy
that picture you can shred it burn it
bury it you can throw darts at it
whatever
and uh after sweet sweet uh catharsis
you get a coupon for 10
wings which you can cash in at a hooters
this valentine's day have you ever been
to a hooters
huh um
well i actually have and um we
adam sandler and i did this movie called
blended and the first scene of the movie
takes place at a hooters and it turns
out his like wife worked there is the
most meaningful sweet storyline
um and they gave me a gift card for
a year's free food and it was laminated
with my pictures on it and the hooters
logo and man i put that in my wallet and
carried it around for years
really did you ever go in and use it you
know i didn't but i
it's like a trophy to me like my picture
next to the hooters emblem i just i love
it i love hooters
and you know it's not just hooters who
wants to help you out when you go
through
a breakup or a divorce your friends
really want to be there for you and
support you and sometimes they don't
know exactly how
word it's like it's sensitive
so a writer at instyle just came up with
this
genius idea of how to do this
she was recently divorced so she went on
zola
which is a wedding registry
site and she opened up a registry
for one and there were so many simple
things that she lost in that divorce
whether it be
pots pans towels and let me tell you
when you get a divorce you do have to
build your life back up
and as cute and quippy as this story
might seem
this one really caught my attention i
think this is awesome
and you don't even have to be married to
go through this you could have just
lived with someone
and i think this is revolutionary
and it's a great way to make a very
difficult situation
celebratory as well as
help solve the problem well i thought
about this you know when i when i
thought she was doing it and i don't
judge her or anybody that would do that
but
when i thought would you do it ross
there's no way i would do it
because i would feel i feel like by
saying i need help i
would feel weak and then i thought why
would you be judging yourself if you
wouldn't judge anybody
else for doing it and i think there's
something is so so strong in saying
hey friends family people i know i'm
struggling i need help i just went
through something really hard
i think that vulnerability is very
strong
and a great way for those who are
tentative on the sidelines
dying to dive in and be proactive with
you which is what friends
do yes i want to help right this
i i just want to say to this writer i
will be offlining and sidelining with
you because i have an idea
inspired by you really yeah yeah oh
will you fill us in later absolutely
stay tuned all right before we go
um we got one thing um that helps in
every breakup valentine's day
celebration you name it
it's ice cream oh my god what are you
doing
and we are loving this nyx
swedish ice cream brand i have eaten
so much of it there's no sugar in here
for reals
yes ross it's all plant-based sweeteners
so it's like a salad
with ranch dressing okay um even though
they actually have vegan options too
and vffs we love you so much and we want
to get you in on this too so you're
getting a 150
gift card one low calorie swedish style
ice cream brand knits and you better use
it
what is going on this is that is so good
it is so
incredible nyx whoa you
are dope and delicious
[Music]